Government is capping immigration again.
Listen to the minister of jobs.
Employers should not use the Temporary Foreign Worker program
as a means to avoid offering competitive wages to Canadians.
There is news for Canadians as well as aspiring and current immigrants.
I'll simplify this announcement as an education influencer
so that you stay informed.
Don't forget to like and follow.
First of all, similar to PR targets,
there will be a cap on temporary work permits
and the minister of immigration mentioned a decline.
We are targeting a decrease in our temporary residence population
to 5% over the next three years.
The second important thing you need to know is about the LMAA
or in simple terms,
the document that allows businesses to hire from abroad.
May 1st, the time for which an LMAA is valid,
that's the labor market impact assessment
will be reduced to six months from the current 12 months.
However, this rule has some exemptions
like in the healthcare and construction sectors.
And there's more not affect agriculture sector
employers or their workers.
Other sectors experiencing seasonal demand like in fishing and seafood,
food processing and tourism
will continue to benefit from a one time
a year seasonal cap exemption.
LMAA is basically me as a business
telling the government that I could not find any Canadian PR
or citizen to fulfill this job.
That's why I need to hire from abroad.
However, something new that the minister brought up
is he wants employers to consider
Asylum seekers as well as under represented groups
like Ukrainians on the work permits.
It's important you share this video and follow to stay informed.